so this this happened just last night
yes uh about 10 o'clock last night a
local resident put on Facebook constant
News and Views about how disgusting and
disgraceful this flight appears the
fabric of our society is made up of many
threads along with it seems carpets and
laundry baskets fly tipping here in
congleton East Cheshire is a very small
strand
but Target at those threads year after
year and it adds up to the sense that
the social fabric the deal between
citizens and state is fraying well
obviously as you can see here we've got
beautiful countryside and it's the real
eyesore so as well as the financial cost
of pulling it all up we are seeing our
area being blighted tempers are fraying
too this driver stopped next to us to
complain you've never used to get
[Applause]
the problems like potholes
this road is on a school route and has
been like this for five years
in Sky News analysis of council spending
confirms that sense of decline in the
everyday activities of councils
spending on roads has dropped from
nearly a billion pounds across all
councils 10 years ago to around 700
million pounds today street lights have
lost 100 million pounds in funding and
that's because councils are spending
more money on social care which they
have a legal duty to provide unlike
roads and Street lighting it's gone from
26 billion pounds 10 years ago to 30
billion pounds today even after
adjusting for inflation please of all my
Atari Jaguar games Cheshire East Council
spends 64 and a half percent of its
Budget on social Care on places like
this and on people like David Ryder
there you go
David's 57 years old lives in full-time
care in congerton and is a massive fan
of 80s New Wave Music
[Music]
the highlights of his month is a disco
for disabled people run by volunteers
other community activities have been cut
by the council do you feel like there's
less services from the government to
help you it's about the government that
did politics weight in mental health and
also physical health
um yeah I think even previous to you
being with us there was a lot more
things funded for you to do wasn't there
yeah and I think we've definitely seen
that cut back
Cheshire East Council told us it was
facing unprecedented Financial pressure
like councils across the country demand
for social care is rising so Cuts have
to be made elsewhere
pulling at those threads yet again
Tom Cheshire Sky News concordon East
Cheshire